hi and welcome to episode number 32 of
the weekly Google plopping for podcast
I'm Frances Cambodian I'm here with my
colleague mark hey Mark how are you
doing I am good friends ask how are you
doing doing great very excited about
today we're going to be talking with
some people with weird accents like you
yeah we're going to be talking to some
people down in New Zealand yep some
Kiwis and we're going to be talking
about how they use two different two
completely different Google products
actually they're gonna a use Google
cloud platform yeah concretely a big
query yep but also google analytics yeah
it's a really interesting conversation
about how they combined those two things
together yep very interesting I
definitely learned a lot so I hope that
you will also enjoy it in there yep but
before that actually not before that but
at the end we will also be talking about
the question of the week that comes from
someone that asks you this question
actually that's one of our teammates
which leads into one of his blog posts
that will talk a little bit some cute
little tidbit to round up engine flex
and two nice little bit best practices
for Benjen flexible environment yeah
previously known as managed VMs yeah now
flexible environment yes so yeah we'll
be talking about there was a little bit
too at the end but before that we're
going to start with the cool thing of
the week yes is pretty exciting stuff so
this cool thing of the week is all
around grp see if you're not familiar
with grp see it's a remote procedure
call framework based out of some work
that's come out of Google it's pretty
awesome a huge fan do you know what grp
C stands for I think we've covered this
Oct RPC remote procedure framework
exactly a fractal fractal fractal name
would ya I love ya yeah perfect there's
a really interesting blog posts that
came up from a company called DeGraff
they have an open-source graph database
that they wrote using using gr pc and
they talk about actually how they go
from and originally using just the go /
RPC so that you go with their primary
language but they ended up wanting to
replace it with gr pc but the
interesting part of it is
gr pc users protobuf by default ID field
yeah just cool but you can actually
switch it out and because of certain
trade-offs they wanted to make with sort
of message size they were sending and
what they were doing on both ends of the
pipe flatbuffers was a better fit for
them and so they talk about why they
made that decision and how they ended up
switching it out because in grp see you
can switch out what your encoding type
is which is really awesome and they sort
of step through all that's a really
really interesting read about taking
that open source project and just
extending it in the way it was meant to
be extended yeah and I actually liked a
lot the blog post because it's very very
very coverage which I really appreciate
it it they describe a little bit what
they're doing but also they just give
you how they actually doing it with all
the code all the detail yeah which I
love I love the fact that they were so
they're like hey this is what it looks
like using net RPC and go here's all the
lines of code and then here's the like
10 lines of code that we now use for grp
see ya yeah it looks break it so well
that's right yeah we'll have a we'll
have a link to that blog post in the
show notes absolutely excellent so we
are having a great chat with Emily and
Lester from New Zealand trade me should
we move to chatting with them let's go
for that sounds good to me today we have
the distinct pleasure of being joined by
two wonderful people from New Zealand
very close to my old home country we are
joined today by Emily bluish and Lester
Litchfield from trade me how are you
both doing today how you doing to Emily
pretty good yeah just another day
another day and you Lester awesome
fantastic so thank you so much for
joining us we really appreciate you
taking the time Jews one of you want to
give us a little bit of background on
say like who you are and what you do why
don't we start with you Lester sure my
name is Lester I'm a data scientist /
web analyst at trade me that means I
helped a lot with things like AP testing
stats and also helping to build products
that incorporate data for prediction
text processing those sorts of things
and also pretty deeply involved in the
web analytics side of things
helping tell the story of how users
behave so that people in abysus can
build stuff that makes them happy
excellent and you Emily hi I'm Emily I'm
a full stack developer here at trade me
so I do a lot of C sharp code so I work
on both the back end and the front end
of the site i also am studying
Electrical Engineering at the same time
because I like software and hardware
equally at the moment I'm doing a lot of
work around big data and how to get a
big data to our other businesses and
also provide insights for our Ellen our
analytics people and yeah it's just been
very interesting to work in data
analytics but sort of from a developer's
perspective and making our business
insights a lot easier for us here at tre
me cool so why don't you tell us in our
our listeners up a little bit about
trade me what what do you do so tre me
is a pretty interesting company and that
is set it off as a marketplace but has
grown to be a sort of way of life this
is so not only is like pretty much
everybody in New Zealand users trade me
to buy and sell stuff we're a nation of
cheapskates we love getting a bargain
and but also when we expand into other
verticals as well so we're one of the
leading job websites in the country one
of the leading auto web sites in the
country one of the leading real estate
sites in the country so we're pretty
broad spanning a big fish in a small
pond if you like um so that's a bit
about trade me yeah we have like a new
zealand we're pretty big we have
something like sixty percent i think of
the web traffic and we have a lot of
people using us a day I guess like to
America we're kind of like Amazon or
Ebay 11 of those sort of sites but just
so lean but New Zealand did you just say
that you get sixty percent of the
traffic in New Zealand that's a bit of a
dodgy steady oh no that is pretty
impressive just curious yeah yeah I mean
we were like that
highest traffic site in New Zealand for
quite some time wow we're still the
second highest from the awesome stats
that's just below one of the major news
sites so yeah we're a phenomenally big
proportional amount of the traffic and
new zealand yeah costly Wow ok cool so
um I know you do some interesting things
with like big data as well as with
Google Analytics integration George talk
is about like how you use google
analytics that trade me sure so Google
Analytics is our web analytics platform
and we use it for heaps of things one to
understand where people come from to get
to the site number two what they do when
they get there what sort of pages
they're using what's what parts of the
products they find useful and what sort
of interactions lead on to kind of goal
completions or things we want people to
do we also use it to measure um an
attribute our marketing spend and we use
it to test then things like conversion
funnels how people move through
processes and then right to the end of
the chain so the value and the outcomes
that different kinds of people are
contributing to the business so we use
it across all our sites in amps so
that's a desktop website and mobile site
and about five or six different and apps
and I'm support for our our side of
things we also use google analytics to
provide business to business insights so
all of our customers like car dealers
real estate agents we provide analytics
to them on their sort of houses and cars
and how or they are faring or treat me
one of the awesome things about GA is
that you able to take information from
lots of different sites and apps and
roll it up and one big master account so
in like Emily's case Motors dealer can
find out how their products are being
interacted with across all of our sites
and platforms cool is there any
particular features of google analytics
that you used to do this sort of stuff
um so very recently Lester has been
using google tag manager and addition to
google analytics and so that in addition
to some google analytics gives you you
know you can get the source the location
of where people are coming from but it
doesn't have things that are quite
custom to car dealers say like the
vehicle model and the vehicle ID or
anything like that so we use Google tag
manager to provide what's called custom
dimensions so on every page view or
click or event we sin through a whole
bunch of data all about what say that
vehicle is that then gets sent into
Google Analytics which we can then
provide we can use to provide insights
on so in addition to basic web data you
can get more specific stuff so goober
tagging are just really good and really
easily ties into Google Analytics yeah
it's pretty cool you can put a Google
tag manager works around a data layer so
that this concept that on the client
side you have this array or this
dictionary which just holds heaps of
data about what's going on at the time
and like a key value store so you have
the name of the car dealer the color of
the car and all those sorts of things
you know sometimes up to 30 or 40
different things and then any actions
that happen on their page like a click
or a page view or an interaction and you
can you can pick which one to those
who'd like to grab bundle it all up and
cinders ahead to Google Analytics so
it's super flexible and it enables you
to to pretty easily pass pretty rich
data around cool so so that basically if
I understand correctly what you're doing
is you're sending a bunch of information
to Google Analytics you were tagging out
in different ways what happens with it
afterwards how do you process it well
mainly you process it that is provided
to us and all these lovely kind of a
built-in reports but increasingly now we
are starting to use integration with
bigquery and the reason that's really
cool is because it gives us access to
the raw data it's totally unsampled and
it enables us to do kind of ad hoc or
pretty complex queries without having to
really worry about compute power and we
don't have the resource internally to
look over a year's web blogs in a
reasonable time frame but
that you guys do so that's that's sort
of how we're using it and Emily could
talk a little bit more about how she's
been using the boo crew API which is
really cool the fact that that massive
massive data store we would spot like 30
40 gigs a day of logs we export to
bigquery and it's all available right
behind an API forum for her to be able
to kind of consuming aggregated or
expose on the website I'll take you back
a step just real quick as well do you
want to talk a little bit about like
what does that process look like for
taking google analytics and pushing into
bigquery is it like just a check box or
is there a lot of work like what had to
happen there um it was sort of part of
the g AP Delia was offered to us as a
feature we thought oh yeah that kind of
looks cool so that when we said you go
ahead do that so they set up a cloud
project for us and then a little bit
later we were like hey we should have a
look and when we had a looker but like
wow this is pretty impressive not only
is there heaps of data there and
especially with a custom dimension stuff
it's really rich but also like the
processing power is not like anything
we've seen before it's sort of the power
of grayskull really when you I got the
reference is so problem you mentioned a
JP deal what I don't know what that
means do you explain that Google
Analytics premium so it's just that the
difference between the free one which is
a you know you have a lot of your data
is sampled down for obvious reasons that
you know when half the web's using it
for free it's pretty hard to provide
loads of processing power for that to
the paid version to the paid version
gives you kind of unsampled reports and
also these integrations and the bigquery
and other kind of premium features I
think that the best way lists are just
described it a few months back was that
Google Analytics was for kids and in
bigquery was for the grown-ups cuz it's
like the real raw daughter in there that
you got a query so yeah Emily Lester was
sort of sending it over to you to talk
about how you use the bigquery API don't
talk a little bit about that yeah sure
um so when we first started with
bigquery it was kind of knew there
wasn't much documentation on how people
were using it so we spent a lot of time
trying to figure out how to use it
eventually of course thankfully there is
an awesome
api that we can use but obviously the
awesome thing about bigquery is you can
run massive queries and a few seconds
time however we were looking at
providing business insights for our
customers and we sort of wanted you know
a dashboard to load within a few
microseconds as opposed or milliseconds
as opposed to you know five seconds that
as a data analytics person you wouldn't
mind but customers might get frustrated
having to wait for data to come through
and because the career I believe have
like a one-second minimum query um so as
we have so much data and bigquery and we
had to figure out a way to get what we
wanted out and be able to query it
quickly and get the data um you know to
our customers basically so for that what
we did is we set up a scheduled appt
with the bigquery API and basically
every day we go to the massive table
which i think is about 3.3 million rows
and we basically query okay grab me all
of this all of these people's listings
on trade me and give me all of the data
and we export that into our own database
and then from there we can have our web
app talk to our database and pull out
the data very very quickly so that was a
pretty good way to do it and it means we
know we can run the schedule appt it's a
3m in the morning it'll be done and
about I think 30 seconds usually I mean
usually we're adding say about 30 gig of
data so every day to get all of the
Lessing's that we need it's about 30 gig
of data putting putting into it which is
quite a bit and i think when i was i
usually like play around with things to
get the queries right and i think the
best our query i got was 480 gigabytes
of data to be clear i don't think it did
it in like 45 seconds or something crazy
nice that was that was pretty awesome so
basically from what i understand you're
basically pulling down aggregate
information from bigquery is that would
that be pretty accurate yeah yeah
definitely yeah because it's got that
level of granularity sometimes you want
to go deep into the debt nesting it's
really interesting actually coming from
a sequel background and doing a lot of
sequel queries where you go you know the
longer you go down your table
longer your query takes but going down
and bigquery is easy it's going right so
increasing the levels of nesting so I'm
still not really sure whether the
bigquery table structure is sequel or
non-sequel like because it you know it
gives you like a tabular format but it's
it's nested and you've got a lot of it
looks almost fast because you've got a
lot of nails so it's some kind of no
sequel sparsity come tabular data format
and there's a few tricks to kind of you
know being able to pull up data from the
lowest level of nesting to the highest
which has been fun to learn about but um
but yeah it works brilliantly so let's
go I'm quite curious ooh like you're a
data scientist how has been having
access to that all that data inside
bigquery change like your job in terms
of how you interact with trade me and
the data provides well previously we
would be able to give very limited
numbers of answers would go as your as
your question addressable work by one of
our metrics and sometimes would be able
to get a half answer by like doing like
30 queries and joining them up but now
like pretty much with Google tag manager
every click is basically available to be
tracked and with bigquery any kind of
condition or process or basically
anything is there so it takes the
pressure off the data and means that
answering the questions is about how
good are you as a as a data scientist
that framing the question and and
bringing through the answers cleaner
kind of clear and to puts the pressure
on the science rather than the data it's
also very easy to have a slight mishap
somewhere and the data and if that
happens a lot of your reporting does
some interesting things so and now
scheduled at which basically you noah
queries all of the big query data what
we actually had to sit up was a lot of
sort of like tests to check that the
data was still coming through correctly
so that was that was quite cool in there
the curry API allows us to do that
pretty easily and has quite good logging
and everything for that cool oh also you
mentioned you do a lot of a be
testing how I know Google Analytics has
some system tools and capabilities built
into that is that changed as well within
bigquery and you have that power or is
it so same how are you doing that we
sometimes use Google Analytics content
experiments um and they work really well
in a sort of a certain scope like my
favorite thing is that it wraps some
like on further reading pretty meaty
bayesian stats and a really nice wrapper
so you don't have to think about it
unfortunately sometimes you do have to
think about it because the framework
doesn't quite fit for the question you
have and the cool thing about like
bigquery is like we use Python quite a
lot internally and so I can go into
Python pull out some aggregates from
bigquery and then run any kind of
statistical processing over that from
say scikit-learn or you know sigh pie or
any of those kind of big scientific
libraries and so it means that yet you
get there the freedom to kind of do a/b
testing however you want based on the on
the data cool so i was wondering at some
point you were talking about the fact
that the way you use bigquery since
since bigquery has that one second
minimum for requests what you do is you
store some aggregates into some
temporary database you tell us a little
bit more about that where is that
database running but kind of day debate
is it it is yeah sure um so for us here
at trade me we have quite a lot of
different databases everywhere so we do
have one big database that stores
basically like the last days data so
what happens is because there's a bit of
delay between getting everything flowing
from trade me to Google tag manager to
Google Analytics then into bigquery and
then our schedule appt to query that we
usually get like the last that
yesterday's data I mean so what happens
is that all gets so in bigquery each day
is a new table and so what happens each
day for us as we append each day's data
to our database and we only hold up
90 days of data at a time so basically
because for business insights we don't
report back on 90 days obviously but if
someone say wants to report on a year's
worth of data what we do is we then go
to big query since the data is already
there so basically we effectively cash
90 days of data and then in bigquery if
we want more data which they just have
to wait more time to sort of get 9 you
know 90 days plus whatever more of data
so that's quite good for us to store the
data that we want immediately but then
if they want more they they can take
more it's an hour sorry it sir there are
my sequel tables I'm curious do you run
your own infrastructure I don't know how
how good the cloud providers are in New
Zealand and how does that like locality
work sure yeah we run our own
infrastructure so we have boxes yeah
remember those days and yeah we have a
ton of boxes 'um we're not sort of like
super distributed as a model like we
sort of were largely on a kind of a
Microsoft stack so this is where it's
quite interesting for us even beyond
analytics when you get into the data
processing where you know the
distributed model start to make a lot of
sense there you know we maybe get a
biscuit looking into how the Google
cloud platform can help provide some of
that distributed kind of processing
power so I'm guessing you you've got
local machines because latency and
because you know your audience is right
there but then when that immediate speed
thing is not not necessary as much and
you're looking at like how do we
elastically scale our data processing
that's when you're sort of stepping into
the class yeah that'd be correct yeah in
the nearest the nearest awss in sydney
in the nearest google data center i
think is in singapore so singapore to
New Zealand's quite far like it's
probably like bigger than the
continental United States so that it's
quite far cool that's actually a very
interesting way of using basically using
the cloud for the part that interests
you and the rest yeah nice uh well I
think that we are almost running out
of time so is there anything that you
would like to add that we have not
mentioned before okay I've total things
one one cool thing because with bigquery
you can basically narrow down on really
really distinct stats and data about a
student view and so without tests that
we run when we're clearing the big crew
API to check the validity of the data
there was a few times when the whole of
the data layer and the law custom
dimensions were now but there was still
a view logged so it was kind of
interesting and it was quite fun because
we got to be all like CSI detective to
see like you know why why is this
happening and what we actually managed
to find was that there was a whole bunch
of listings hit at the exact same time
stamp with the exact same browser ID
when they hit all of these listings and
so what we actually managed to find out
is that these were obviously BOTS like
scraping through the site and they
obviously went through it fast enough
that the data layer didn't have time to
populate and be sent to GTM properly so
that was pretty interesting i think i
was on skype with lisa being like oh my
gosh there's these bots and so he would
like i'll block their browser ids and it
was kind of caught was like a little way
detective moment to sort of be like
Autobots and block them from our data so
they don't sort of mess with it so I
thought that was pretty awesome to see
that happening and then be able to sort
of stop them from affecting our data
that was pretty cool nice let's say you
got anything nothing that cool that is
fine uh well I think we're running out
of time so thank you very much for
taking the time to chat about trade me
with us today thank you yeah thanks
having us thank you so much thank you so
much again Emily and Lester for such an
interesting interview I hope you learned
as much as I did it was very interesting
to see how two different pieces of
Google can collaborate together to make
analytics even better yeah I mean I've
only personally ever just kind of
plugged in out google analytics and just
kind of let it sit there yeah we do know
it I mean that's
podcast really like yeah I've google
analytics is like the most basic thing
we can do yeah so it's actually really
interesting to see how people kind of
pushing the envelope in terms of what
you can do with it yeah maybe maybe you
should add some of those features to the
podcast me maybe you should add them
yeah pull requests are welcome anyway so
let's move on let's go with a question
of the week but actually before we do
the question of the week there was a
little cool thing of the week which is
it's maybe we should create a new
section which is not cool thing of the
week is a cute thing of the week it is
pretty adorable it is the most adorable
guide to cover Nettie's I've ever seen
it is it's an the name is the
illustrated children's guide to Coober
Nettie's and if you have a kid and the
kid wants to learn how to use Cooper
Nettie's and what it is and love like
cartoons and giraffes and cute Gophers
it is just the perfect video oh really
if you're just a kid at heart I'm I know
I'm gonna watch it later it is really
you definitely should watch it yeah it
is very very good so we'll also have a
link to that one on the show notes it is
adorable but now for real we're gonna go
with the question of the week which was
about avenging flex a pension flexible
environment so what was the question so
the question was around like how do you
shut down an app engine flex project
like say you're prototyping or trying
something out maybe proof of concept
something like that you don't want to
have it running all the time now one of
the trade-offs with App Engine flex is
you get you know a lot more flexibility
you can do it if you want but it doesn't
scale 20 yeah so you might want to shut
it down now previously this was kind of
tricky yet to kind of jump through some
loopholes and like do some fun things
and it wasn't great the great thing is
now there's a simple command and allows
you to do it nice and what is the
command so it's a version specific
command so you're like hey I want you to
shut down this version okay so you can
say g-cloud preview app versions stop
and then the version name you want to
shut down nice so simple it's pretty
simple so you can kind of work on
something for a few hours or your day
and then once you're done at the end of
the day shut it down and you have to
worry about paying for it very cool that
sounds like very useful especially you
you are like once your application is on
production and people you actually have
like real traffic please don't do that
yeah yeah but if you're just like
getting started and you're working on it
like once a week and stuff like that
yeah it's probably worth saving having a
bit of a couple sends in there well it's
really cool actually one of our
teammates Sandeep wrote a whole blog
post that will put in the show notes
just discussing like how to how to make
savings like cost savings when doing
prototyping or proof of concepts with
that bench and flex and you go through
some best practices and things you can
do to really bring those costs down
until you're ready to bring in like all
that that real traffic and have that
come in so well worth a read we'll put
that in the show notes very cool so I
think that kind of brings to an end all
of our stuff for today France esque are
you going to be anywhere special in the
next few weeks so yes next week that
will be actually none next week but the
week after that I will be in Denver for
gopher come yes yeah very excited about
that it is a it is one of my favorite
conferences so I'm gonna be very very
excited and I believe you're doing
something something pretty special there
yeah I'm kind of doing an opening
keynote it seems so that's something
just a little of something yeah yeah
it's gonna be fun to be on stage and see
like I think it's 1500 Gophers looking
at you yeah yeah yeah that's what
nightmares are made of yeah just
remember to just remember you know I
don't know don't do anything too
embarrassing but well we'll see what
about you what are your fence um so when
this podcast releases the day after that
I will be in New York foreplay crafting
in New York there's gonna be Google
panel there and I have some other events
coming up nothing's quite confirmed yet
so so we'll see what happens cool well
you can tell us more next week
absolutely great well thanks so much
again thank you Mark for sharing the
time here today with me and thank you
our listeners for being there absolutely
and again if you have questions comments
concerns you feel like just saying hi
love having people do that sort of stuff
and we love people say we love people
yeah yeah absolutely well see you all
next week see you next week
you